[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time i'm
rachel and it's great to meet you
today actually marks a full year of the
data science hangout
and i just want to say thank you to
everyone for
making it what it is and for hanging out
with us
from that first one which was kind of an
experiment of seeing how things were
going to go to what it is now
this is always
a favorite part of my week now
we are going to
take a break from hangouts in july as we
prepare for the r studio conference and
some big announcements
so let us know in the chat too if you'll
be there at the conference we'd love to
see you all in person as well
but we'll be right back with normal
hangouts right after the conference on
thursday august 4th as well
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to
connect and chat about data science
leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
these sessions are recorded and shared
to youtube as well as the data science
hangout site
so you can always go back and re-watch
or find helpful resources there too
we also have a linkedin group i want to
make sure i mention if you ever want to
continue certain discussions there
and hannah can share it
in the chat as well
but before we get started here there's
three ways um that you can ask questions
um you can jump in by raising your hand
on zoom
you can put questions into the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it
or i can call you to introduce yourself
and add some context to
but lastly we also have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
as well
and hannah will share that as well i
think you just shared it right when i
said it
but we always want to create spaces
where everybody can participate and we
can hear from everyone
no matter your level of experience or
area of work as well
but with all that thank you again for
joining us today i'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host today rebecca hatty
head of data science at lynn health
and rebecca i'd love to kick things off
with having you introduce yourself and
sharing a little bit about your work
and introducing your cat here as well
yeah absolutely thanks so much for
having both myself and my cat jinx she
was really excited for the hangout today
clearly so thanks so much for having us
um yeah so my name is rebecca hattie and
i'm the head of data science at lynn
health
lynn health is a early stage startup and
we're focusing on
serving members who have multiple
chronic conditions and building a
healthcare experience that really
supports the whole person
so from a data science perspective my
role
and the work my team does kind of
buckets into
kind of three or four different areas um
so at a high level we're a very small
team i'm a data engineer in my team and
we work together to build out our data
warehouse
and that's where we
ingest data from both our clients our
own electronic health record system
and make it
kind of easier for access and also
trying to build out self-service
capabilities for other other teams so we
aren't quite so much the bottleneck so
that's one area um another area is sorry
my cat's like all of them my girl
another area is
trying to support
identification of members who might be a
good fit for our program and we do that
by
building algorithms to measure something
uh called impactability so in healthcare
you can imagine that
you know you hear these horror stories
of
you know
hospital stays that are thousands of
dollars and very expensive medications
and things like that
but not all of those things
are
like impactable you know like some of
those things you couldn't really have
done anything about so we're trying to
take the transition from
just someone's risk like how
like you know kind of traditional
healthcare space it's like a risk score
you know like what is your predicted
spend but we're kind of trying to shift
the perspective
to what's your impactable spend um and
using that as sort of a main signal for
who do we think is a good candidate for
our program who has the most
spend out using our methods we think
that we can impact um so that's another
vertical and then the third
one is
building
internal risk adjustment models to help
us normalize comparisons between
different physicians so we're focused on
looking at outcomes so one example is
inpatient mortality so we built a risk
adjustment model
that is able to sort of predict when an
inpatient mortality will happen with a
high degree of accuracy and we can use
that to adjust for providers case mix to
say you know just because they see a
secret group of patients we don't want
to penalize them for that
but use that to be able to detect
statistically significant variation um
in the
in their inpatient mortality rates as an
example and we use that to inform who we
want to refer to so we want to send
patients
to doctors who have you know
statistically better outcomes um and
then the last one
is more of a kind of sales support focus
and we support our sales team and one of
the favorite things that we did was um
we built a our shiny interactive sales
tool for them we got some it was
initially built as an excel model but we
got some feedback that
you know we'd love to kind of have a
slider that we can do live in meetings
and our shiny was a great tool to
achieve that um so we have a like shiny
uh server instance that we host that
tool on so i just talked a lot but those
are that's a little bit about the
different pockets of work uh
under my scope at one health
awesome that's really helpful
and and what does your data team look
like today
yeah um it's a pretty small data team so
it's actually myself and and one data
engineer
so my role is um you know it's a lot of
hands-on keys individual contributor
work in addition to
supporting uh you know the growth and
career of big data engineer and making
sure that you know he's able to learn
different things and build relationships
with the business and then also that
that strategy component of you know what
what strategically will help the
business what does our roadmap look like
well we yeah we've talked about that
before on data science hangouts how
um when you're the first data person
there can be there's a lot of decisions
that you have to make and
sometimes can be a little scary um but
how do you handle being
one of the first data people there
yeah um it was definitely a bit of a
learning curve
um i think that
um
i think one of the biggest challenges i
faced was initially just not having
uh any of our own data
so for a while when i first started we
didn't have any sort of products or
systems that were generating data so a
big thing that i had to do was
uh kind of search for what publicly
available data
could we leverage to answer some of the
questions that we have so that was
definitely an initial challenge
um and then also
kind of more of an opportunity as a
first data person was just helping
the organization see the value of data
science and really being an advocate for
uh you know
using the work that myself slash what
grew into my team uh produces to really
drive decision making so but you know to
be honest it can be a little bit
isolating um i've worked previously at
larger organizations where like at
nordstrom for instance there was a large
center of excellence so i was a part of
a community with
you know i think it was around 100
people of different data science
analysts engineers so
it can be a little bit isolating but
that's why i love events like this and
other things in the community where i
can still have those technical
relationships uh and you know kind of
talk to other people so that's a little
bit about what it's been like as the
first day to hire
absolutely thank you um ishwar i see you
put a question to the chat do you want
to jump in and ask that
um hey hi everyone um this is ishwar i
currently work at nissan supply chain as
a data scientist
so yeah i'm
really excited to
um
you know know about the how data science
journey of rebecca harris had started in
her organization
um
and i was in the same situation when i
started at nissan
specifically in my department my team
so um
i had i had a lot of challenges with the
a lot of unstructured data like xml
format and super unorganized and then
not having anyone to help for
on the data engineering task and getting
those data from you know multiple places
into the organized structure and then at
least data
scraping from
xml to structure tables and don't even
know where to store the data so those
were the initial faces and i was i
didn't even have a data engineer um to
start i was just you know dead end that
i don't have anywhere anywhere to go
kind of stuff so um
yeah i i totally you know feel your um
how you might have started your data
science journey so just try to
understanding even more like how
did you at least kick start your journey
um at least to prove the you know proof
of concept to the organization that hey
data science if we grow from one data
scientist and one data engineer to the
larger data science
whole team
then um definitely the organization
may benefit um from that team so
what was the challenge that you faced to
go and get started with your proof of
concept
um
just wanted to you know understand in
high level your journey um
to grow up uh and then make
creating the trust within the
organization
yeah absolutely so you're trying to
understand um you know how did i sort of
convince the business about the value of
data science that's sort of worth the
investment of course yeah okay
yeah um that's a great question i would
say that i'm still very much on that
journey
um
you know just given with
the economy sort of being what it is
we've had to make some pauses and some
of the hiring um that i was hoping to do
so but it's i think it's less about
i feel like i've done the work to sort
of convince the business that it's worth
the investment and now it's more just
like okay when's the right time to sort
of make that investment just based on
some of the economic conditions that
have shifted
um but i think in terms of like how i
built that trust
and i would say um probably the first
project i that i did
developing our pricing model was very
well received by the business and that
was because it was sort of this
vague question of you know how like how
are we going to demonstrate
like
um like where do we think that we're
going to have the most impact and also
how do we do that without having any of
our own data in-house so it was a pretty
significant literature review
that i did trying to understand you know
the ahrq has a lot of really great
research papers about the challenges of
people who have multiple chronic
conditions they're over indexing and
inpatient admissions and ed visits as
well so there's that like utilization
component but then there's also just
frankly a price component there's
significant variation um
in price of different hospitals and so
how i was able to kind of convince the
business of kind of the worth of my team
was building something out of nothing
right and so it was sort of like if i
can take these
very distinct
kind of publicly available
uh like research papers and build a
cohesive story where it has to be based
in reality and it has to be reasonable
but building that into an actual savings
model that i and i think a big part of
it um
you know kind of jumping around in my
answer but
i think communication is a really big
part of it honestly
um and driving adoption
of the work where
you know i could have taken the approach
where it's sort of like you know i'm
gonna go off and build this savings
model and i'm gonna come back and
yeah there you go but i kind of took a
different approach where
you know i brought them along throughout
the process where
you know i met with them
like every week or so and kind of said
you know this is this is where i'm at
this is what i'm seeing this is what
it's looking like and then getting their
feedback at that point
and then integrating that feedback as as
i
went along and then the final delivery
of the product where you know i walked
them through it at a very detailed level
and kind of answered questions so i
would say it's kind of about that like
bringing them along throughout the
process and creating that visibility
into the work kind of rather than um
you know i kind of sometimes have the
urge to like put on my headphones and go
in a k for two weeks and like just kind
of bang something out but i have to
challenge myself to really like bring my
stakeholders along uh that helps them
develop ownership um so i would say that
that's that worked really well for me
yeah um did you have any challenge like
i always face this challenge from the i
um you know i t infrastructure team
letting
a lot of security restrictions on tool
sets like i want to use the anaconda
navigator um you know whole set of
rstudio and spider typical notebooks and
so on and then
the another challenge is not having any
um
pre-established like data sources let's
say oracle a lot of companies have
snowflake aws whatever that is
but me not having those infrastructure
in the beginning uh did you encounter
like those kind of issues like you are
trying to convey the
is team
and and then
it's hard them to explain why do i need
it um and then like it was the major
challenges did they have to face
anything any short of that
or you're in the beginning face of it
yeah
um yeah i would say that i haven't
really faced challenges from our it
department uh in that respect um it was
a while before we on onboarded any
uh sort of like
detailed um you know like p like
information that contained phi or
protected health information or personal
information so it was a while before
um and kind of at that point the
the it organization was kind of pursuing
on this like sock two
kind of audit track and
so i think maybe the reason why i didn't
have that challenge was because i have a
really great relationship like with our
cto with our i.t person and kind of just
again kind of goes back to communication
like kind of telling them what i
anticipate the need like the needs will
be and so they were fine with us kind of
standing up a redshift instance um
we
the i would say the one challenge that
we had is that we are initially planning
to use
uh tableau online for a as a data
visualization like kind of hosting it um
but
we had some confusion on whether or not
that was hipaa compliant um we had done
some research that you know tableau
online was the compliant but then when
we actually went to
sort of go push data up there we
realized well no actually because it's
tab the tab like tableau hosting it like
their backend wasn't hipaa compliant
whereas like but we didn't have the it
resources to stand up a our own tableau
like server instance so we had to pivot
to using
uh amazon quick site um just for kind of
like this dashboard uh that that we were
building so that that was definitely a
pivot where we didn't have the budget to
or the like resourcing to stand up like
a tableau server even though
yeah for me tablets a little bit easier
to use the quick site
you see um i see libby kind of had a
question along those lines as well
um around hipaa libby do you want to
jump in
sure i just realized my camera was
covered and not on
yeah you see you kind of touched on it a
little bit my question immediately was
like i also work in a heavily regulated
industry financial services retail
banking insurance stuff like that
so i know that sometimes those
regulations can cause
a lot of barriers to just being able to
do the work
so what have you experienced around that
but it sounds like you guys are still in
some of the early stages where like
maybe you haven't hit some of those
barriers at scale yet
yeah i would say we haven't really hit
those points at scale i think the main
barrier that we hit was that the tableau
one that i just talked about but it is
something that we're very uh mindful of
when it comes to like installing sort of
different python libraries that we use
um our it's kind of on our roadmap i
think that's called like
snap like snyk i'm really terrible at
pronouncing things
there are kind of tools that we know
about that could kind of help with that
like security audit from like a library
perspective um so i think that like in
the future will be helpful to us but
that's we're just kind of it's always
present in our mind like we don't really
take that
for um you know for granted we're always
thinking about you know
how is this gonna impact security if i
use this kind of like random thing or
push data in a certain place so i would
say we're very
cautious about
about that but we haven't
um kind of to your point we're a little
bit on the earlier side to
experience those challenges at scale
awesome thank you
good question
rebecca i love the point you made about
communication too and just like even
when you want to go like work for two
weeks in your cave with your headphones
on like making sure to have regular
check-ins with the team but i was
curious what that like actually looks
like in practice
like do you just keep like sharing with
the team or just have like regular
check-ins scheduled
yeah i would say that my approach has
evolved over time um we're pretty like
slot based company and i'm a big
proponent of
transparent work and visible work so a
couple of things that i do
um we have a
across like a channel a data science
channel that's open to the company so we
have like our team channel that's more
about like i'm going to be late today or
whatever
but we have an open channel where any
time that we like let's say that we do
an analysis for the sales team um we
post it in that channel and tag the
sales team so like anyone in the company
can can see that work um and we kind of
try to
keep conversations in that channel
versus kind of dms like we'll route
people back to there like let's have
that conversation so because
a lot of times someone else might be
interested in that in that work um so
that's one way and then the other thing
that we've done is we've created just
like a google sheet that we call like
our insight repository so and we have
that pinned to our channel and so when
we post those analyses we also put them
in our insight repository where it's
just like one row per analysis that's
like the analysis wise like inpatient
mortality model um here's a link to the
pdf and then here's like kind of the
insight or like the headline and then a
link to the github but that's just more
for our team so that insight repository
has been really well well received um as
a place that's like okay if you have a
question like start here and you might
just be already um to have that and then
kind of the third
i guess like maybe there's two more
things that i do um i host a weekly like
data science prioritization meeting uh
we use monday as our project management
tool i've used here in the past but i
actually like monday and it was kind of
new for me to use but it's really snazzy
um and there that's been really helpful
from a prioritization perspective
because you know i've had some
challenges in the past struggling
requests from like our clinical team
versus our sales team like what's the
priority and it can be kind of hard to
be that middle person that's like you
know sales team one this time it's like
sorry clinical team i'm not going to be
able to do that kind of you know not
like a shoot the messenger situation but
it's a lot it's a lot more productive
when we can all have that conversation
you know live and say this you know
sales team might say i need xyz for a
meeting and we might say like okay you
know that's going to push off these
additions to this clinical dashboard and
then the clinical team is like okay you
know we're okay with that because of
like xyz reasons so it's just helpful to
have that like kind of prioritization
meeting where you know there's the list
of work and people can see it um so
that's really helpful and then the last
thing is just kind of having i'm a
really big advocate we have a monthly
like all-employee call and i try to get
air time there like pretty frequently to
just kind of talk about
you know initially like a level set of
like this is what data science is and
how my team operates and a big part of
that that's been successful for me is
kind of setting this idea of like if you
ask me something
i'm going to ask you like the why behind
it and i've had instances in my career
where
people can get kind of defensive when i
ask that question you know like i'm
and maybe it was just my historical
wording of it but it really helped to
kind of set that precedent ahead of time
where it's
i'm not like challenging
you or this idea but it will help my
team produce better work if we
understand like why you care about this
how are you like how are you going to
use it because we can that gives us
context and you know decisions that we
might need to make throughout the
process so that was a really long answer
but those are some of the things that i
do um to kind of help with communication
and building relationships
that's incredibly helpful thank you
um i think david you just asked the
question and libby plus wanted it right
away so
david do you want to ask that
sure thank you i'm rachel
um so rebecca my question is really
around that you're building your team
do you plan or have you thought through
whether you're going to have one
centralized group of data scientists
that support the entire organization or
your group or do you think about maybe
embedding data scientists in those
functional groups so they get an idea of
that don't just that domain and work
with it like that just just your
thoughts on that
yeah that's a great question um
my current thought about it i'm i'm
planning on starting with a centralized
data science team uh mainly to just
establish
kind of like standards and and processes
around you know kind of like we talked
about like from a security perspective
um and
some different kinds of methods that we
use so i'm planning on starting with a
centralized
team but then my goal would be that as
we
kind of continue to build our
self-service tools and up level the
skill of our business partners um to
kind of do some of their own like
initial analyses that in the future i
really like the idea of the embedded
model where the person sits under the
data science team and can benefit from
that technical mentorship and
you know knowledge sharing resources but
then are aligned to a specific vertical
because i think domain
knowledge is just so important
and that it can be hard when you're
working on a bunch of different things
to
really get get deep in that so
once we grow i'm a big fan of the
embedded model for just building that
like developing those team-specific
relationships and that team kind of team
specific domain knowledge
all right thank you
i see luke you had a comment on that as
well not to put you on the spot but if
you want to jump in
i see luke just said huge hub and spoke
advocate yes well
oh i'm sorry i finally figured out how
to use my
microphone again um
yeah especially in healthcare
like
there is a big
there's a big need for like a hub and
spoke model i think
um
i know personally i'm bespoke for my
department
and it's almost like you need that
person to be like the liaison between
the central group and
you know what
and you can be as the spoke all
needs in the department
so it's one of those
in health care i would really advocate
for that
that's a great point
i see that blake you had asked the
question a little bit earlier about
redshift do you want to jump in
yeah let's see if i can get this uh i
don't know if my video is going can you
hear me on the on the audio check yes i
can
we can see youtube i i suppose it's a
little bit more technical than the uh
the managerial and the team structuring
and uh some of the organizational
hurdles but um i noticed you mentioned
that you went redshift so are you um are
you in a specific cloud environment like
aws right now and is that what led you
to redshift and i was just i don't have
a lot of experience with redshift i was
wondering what some of the tradeoffs
were with that versus other database
technologies and whether or not you have
a cloud hybrid or if that had something
to do with it over
yeah that's a great question um the
reason that we chose redshift was
because both myself and my data engineer
came from nordstrom and in nordstrom the
database that we had used was redshift
in an aws environment
so that's not to say that
you know it's because it's just what we
used before but the benefit of that was
speed and not having to learn um sort of
like a new
like sql flavor or we've already had a
lot of experience with like ec2 instance
instances and moving data between s3 and
redshift and those kind of different
types of processes so
i would say that the kind of main
deciding factor was just that kind of
speed and we were already familiar with
it so the learning curve there wasn't
really a learning curve and we could get
to the work more quickly um if if that
hadn't been the case i think we would
probably would have done a bit more
exploration on different tools um but
that was really kind of like the driving
factor um of that decision
cool if you're okay with that i have one
take it question um
on on your initial like upfront
investments so um with uh getting your
company to
buy into the costs of the cloud
environment um was that a challenge uh
and was that an upfront investment or
did you have to kind of prove your worth
before they decided to
to hop in that hop on this costs over
yeah um
our cto is
you know very much on board with the
cloud technology so that wasn't so much
of a hard sell but we actually were able
to take advantage of um like an aws like
redshift trial so we got the first two
months of our instance free and in that
time we were able to like produce some
different sorts of analyses that really
sort of drove value for the business so
then after that
um you know it was kind of an easy sell
to say you know we need to continue to
invest in this um and i also think that
recently we were approved applied for
and approved as part of like an aws
startup that has um you know like a
certain amount of aws
credit and so kind of taking advantage
of those resources uh also helped to
help to
build the case if that answers your
question
absolutely above and beyond thank you so
much
thank you sepp i see you put a question
into the zoom chat too if you want to
jump in next
first up i can read your question if you
want to add more context after i didn't
have my microphone on with it okay
you could tell that i was animating i
knew you were here yeah yeah exactly um
uh thanks rebecca for joining and taking
the time to answer questions i
personally get excited because it's
someone that's uh in a similar similar
field um and so my question's a little
bit more
probably specific but i was just curious
you know you guys have built your own
emr um how do you deal with like the
structured versus unstructured data
that's in your emr and you know if and
possible like changing scope over time
if you guys have encountered that yet
yeah um so we use athena health as our
emr um and one of the services that they
offer is called dataview um which is a
snowflake uh like database instance that
they manage and so that's actually made
it like pretty
um like easy for us to access that data
because they're they kind of like build
like a database structure and so we're
still
oh yeah sorry yeah electronic medical
record um
so
the data that we've accessed from that
so far has mostly been structured data
and we actually one of the kind of tools
that we built
um was what we call like a prm or
patient relationship management so you
can kind of imagine like the concept of
a crm um but
you know crms are pretty expensive and
so we built this sort of homegrown
solution leveraging uh data from
dataview and uh snowflake has really
nice python connectors and we're able to
automate that
we use dexter as our sort of like
workflow
automation tools so that was sort of
like a really big one to be able to
automate like the pulling of appointment
data uh and patient data sort of like
into this uh kind of spreadsheet that
then our clinical team can use whereas
before they were having to manually
export csvs every night and like copy
and paste it and so i would say that we
haven't really dealt too much with
unstructured data from the emr
but that's something we're still very
much exploring because like for the note
uh specifically like there's a lot of
good information there that we're going
to want to extract around like social
history questions and things like that
um
i would say when kind of earlier on we
explored some different partners like
particle health and like redox that were
more about leveraging um data from like
the
network of electronic health record
systems so like if i have a patient
um you know how can i get data from
providers that they've already seen
before in an automated way and that's
where i dealt with more of that like
unstructured data because kind of the
truck we just worked with like a trial
we ended up not pursuing that at that
point but that was more like the json
like nested structure um and so that was
definitely a learning curve for me kind
of like working with that and trying to
pull out what i needed but we haven't
had a like very big use case for working
with the unstructured data um yet
cool thanks for answering that
another cat sightings up
where are my cats
um patrick i see you have your hand
raised you want to jump in
sure thank you rachel i appreciate that
and uh rebecca thank you for taking the
time to talk to us about this
similar to sep i'm coming from a similar
content area so i'm gonna ask a bit of a
nitty-gritty question i'd appreciate uh
an answer but i don't wanna take up too
much time with this because i think it's
probably all that applicable to
everybody else
um
i'm wondering about how y'all handle
your record linkage and deduplication
for patients across emrs across data
sources um specifically about uh you
know checking the quality of those
things we're working with a couple of
health information exchanges and we need
to verify quality of their you know uh
patient identifiers
and we've tried a bunch of different
things um
i'm sure you know there there are i can
myriad problems with any single approach
to this and so i'm just wondering what
you all do and how you handle uh that
particular problem
yeah that's a great question um i would
say that
we're not at the point of maturity yet
where we're really leveraging data from
the health information exchange so we
haven't had to do a ton of mapping um
the main mapping exercise that we've
done is making the connection between
the claims data that we receive from our
clients which has you know like a member
id like a health plan member id um and
the patient id uh that we have from our
athena instance and so you know we're
using logic that's like
you know first name last name date of
birth like that kind of matching um but
we haven't had to deal with the
challenge of leveraging data from the
health information exchange so that's
probably not super helpful um in a past
life working at nordstrom uh customer
identity management was like a huge huge
problem
um that
required a lot of work and skepticism
about the customer id and different
databases uses use different customer id
so if you ask someone like how many
customers do we have and if you
used a cust key you got a certain answer
and if you used a wallet you got a
different answer and so that that was a
really big challenge mainly from like a
stakeholder management perspective and
it was kind of building that data
literacy of
you know if i'm asking about customers
like do i care about customers that we
can actually
like send an email to and we have high
uh likelihood that we know who they are
or am i okay with the more probabilistic
assignment to kind of have
um you know maybe capture people who we
aren't able to target them directly but
you know we think that they're a
distinct customer so my answer is
probably not super helpful to your
question
well thank you it is it is just good to
know um sep thank you for the
recommendation i did not know dave on
but uh i will look into that
um and yeah rebecca when when y'all
venture more into that and i'm sure that
is coming somewhere in your future
i i wish you uh much luck and i'd be
happy to talk uh it's uh it's a
challenge for sure um but uh but i
appreciate just sort of the
feeling that y'all are thinking about
this and and that i guess we can explore
like you said nordstrom customer
management is a similar kind of problem
so maybe we should look a little bit
more broadly than we have been so thank
you yeah great question
awesome thank you i see there's a few um
anonymous questions coming in on slido
too so just a reminder if anybody wants
to ask there
we'll share it in the chat again too
but the question was i'm a recent
graduate and
hoping to become a data scientist in the
pharmaceutical space do you have any
tips on how i could help prepare for
interviews
yeah um that's a great question the best
advice that was ever given to me
was that data science is a contact sport
um and what the what they mean by that
is that the best way to learn is by
doing um and you know
my recommendation for trying to get kind
of break into the field would be
especially if you know which domain
um you know find a find a data set
that's on the internet kaggle is a
really great race resource for public
data sets and
just
do something with it right like it can
be as simple as an exploratory data
analysis you can take it further and do
some kind of like predictive model or
like an inference type of task and then
put that on a github profile and if you
kind of want to go above and beyond like
i have a personal website where i
um it's just a google site so it's not
any fancy web development but i but i
write about the work that i do and i
link it to my github and i have that on
my resume
so i found that that really helped to
has helped me in my career and it gives
me something to talk about in an
interview and so that would be my
recommendation is just find a data set
that you're interested in whether it's
related to pharmacy that you're
interested in breaking into or
you know there's lots of like there's
like a where i live um there's like a
pet license database and you can just do
like different sorts of fun things like
that um so that would be my my biggest
recommendation
thank you that's really helpful i see
deepsha also recommended participate in
tidy tuesdays
yeah exactly that's a great idea
um just want to check over on oh a
follow-up to that question anonymously
was
do you think it's important to like
know all the different pharma keywords
or know the keywords that people use in
certain industries
when interviewing for a role
um i would take my opinion on this with
a grain of salt um
i think it depends on
what they're like looking for in that
role like if they're looking for someone
to hit the ground running or to kind of
like mentor others in that specific
domain
then building some of that domain
knowledge will probably be helpful um
but my hiring practice is that i'm i'm i
look more about uh like aptitude and
like curiosity so it's okay like in my
opinion like it's okay if you don't come
in with that expertise but maybe if you
shut like researched it a little bit and
you could kind of turn that back on the
interviewer like you know i saw that
there was a certain term you know like
is that applicable to your work and kind
of more that like curiosity and like
maybe you researched it a little bit but
you don't have to
in my opinion come in sort of like
knowing everything about the um about
the domain
it's really helpful thank you
i was curious rebecca what it was like
for you moving from a retail space at
nordstrom
into your role now and
what was yeah what was that experience
like switching industries
yeah so i actually kind of have a bit of
like a healthcare sandwich in my career
um because i started out working in
healthcare at a couple different health
insurance companies and so i had a lot
of experience working with like medical
claims data pharmacy claims data like
enrollment data i had worked on um
never building a risk adjustment model
of my own but like leveraging software
and
kind of tangential to your question but
like one of my favorite memories of like
early in my career was we used this risk
adjustment software
i think it was called like dxcg
and i was asking questions
to people in the department about you
know how exactly does this work you know
what it like what
inputs like kind of might change the
result and no one could give me sort of
like a firm answer and so i realized
that no one had read the documentation
on this model and that was actually an
opportunity for me
because i printed you know printing was
big at the time so i printed out this
like 30 page document and read it and i
actually became sort of the subject
matter expert and i was it was able to
partner with it whenever we had a
version upgrade because i would read the
release notes and know like okay we need
to pick a sample that has like these
kind of qualities because i expect like
you know they made a significant change
to like neonates or something like that
so kind of a tangent to your question um
but then transitioning into retail
you know i knew nothing about marketing
um at the time but it's
i'm just a very like continuous
learner and i love to learn about new
things so i
and kind of going back in into
healthcare it's somewhere where you know
i had kind of had some background in it
but a lot had changed in the time since
i had left and gone back so
i think my my attitude towards it is
just being comfortable with uncertainty
and just being
um not necessarily attaching pride
to knowing everything about a domain um
and ask and just being very open about
asking questions and clear like you know
i don't understand that can you explain
that to me or i haven't seen that before
and just kind of having that courage uh
to ask those questions made both of
those transitions really uh helpful for
me
or even if it's something that you know
a little bit about just being clear
about like the amount that you know like
i've heard of that but i don't know much
about it you know so kind of
that that made the transition
uh
go well for me i would say
that's really helpful um yeah and i see
ravanda commented always be learning is
great life advice as well
how
how do you balance that in like a busy
role where you just have so much going
on in so many tasks and people asking
you for things to still make time for
learning
i think i've gotten better at that over
time
um
i
when i worked at nordstrom nordstrom oh
i see you've got a cat now nice full
circle my game to make an appearance
here
oh so cute and fluffy oh my gosh i love
cats clearly
um but at nordstrom they were very like
up front about
carving out that time for
self-development and so we would
actually include that as part of our
like jira stories so you know if we have
like
if there's 10 days
in a sprint we would only plan for like
eight points worth of work to allow kind
of that extra two days for
meetings and then carving out that
self-development time but then it
becomes
actually doing it you know like if i
have my self-development time set up for
a friday afternoon do i just like stop
working early and not do it or like
actually kind of do it so i think for me
um it's kind of about like creating like
a little bit of a plan about you know
what is it that i want to learn
and
um
like how do i say this
i think for me like sometimes for me i
get this idea that i have to sit down
and like completely learn something in
that session
and so if i think like if i don't have
three hours to go through this whole
thing then it's just gonna be
like not a good idea but over time i've
learned where it's like it's okay to
start something and not finish it and
that's helped me more kind of learn new
things where i'm like not setting super
high expectations on myself or i can
just kind of play around with something
um i would say the other technique that
i have is
um i kind of did some self-reflection
and realized which part of the day that
i'm the most productive um i was i'm
kind of i'm an introvert and so i was i
used to have a lot of meetings in the
morning
and so i would have my meetings from
like 8 30 to like 12 and then i'd have
the afternoon to work but i would just
be like so drained from that and then
i'm just like i don't want to do
anything and really have to convince
myself and so once i realized that
i'm i'm able to get a lot more done in
the morning and so i moved my i had the
ability to move my off meetings um to
the afternoon so then i would be able to
have that concentrated time in the
morning where i could be hands-on keys
either doing a project or kind of
exploring something new
and then having my meetings during that
time where i've already kind of you know
i did what i wanted to do today and now
i can focus on more of that
communication aspect so a little bit
beyond the scope of just
self-development but more just about how
i'm kind of managing meetings with
actually kind of getting things done
i love that yeah i realized that too and
i there was a book that i read called
when it was just all about timing of
things in your life
and i realized that about like monday
mornings no matter what are never going
to be a good time for a meeting
i see a lot of great comments in the
chat but i want to make sure i'm not
missing questions in there
too
um
let's see
libby i see you had a comment on
you and lots of apps that you used to
track stuff um was there anything you
wanted to add in
um i think this was a follow-up to a
question about where to find data
um and
it's just a source that like i have
found in my life i'm a
serial data collector like i collect
data and i track a lot of things
and i have for years and years so i kind
of realized that some of these apps that
i use
they have little export options if you
go in the settings export data and it'll
email you a csv file of all the stuff
you've tracked over the past however
many years you've been using that app
um and an example for that for me is i
used to track my sleep really habitually
with a sleep tracking app that listened
to your breathing and stuff like that um
and i ended up with like two and a half
years worth of daily sleep data and
that's stuff that you can
you can bring in external variables
right like
the temperature the precipitation
whatever is going on that day and then i
could also sync that with
my school schedule like was i in school
that day what was the day of the week
like all this stuff just fun little
project so look at your apps what are
you tracking if you're a data person
you're probably tracking a lot in your
life
that's super cool i i love that
uh rwanda i see how to comment um this
kind of data being very useful for
clinical trials um do you have anything
you'd want to share on that
sure just
there have been more trials where people
have been getting personal trackers to
track things like their heartbeat
and it kind of helps to like a lot of
times one of the challenges in clinical
trials is that people have to go to a
certain test site and that's not always
possible especially within the last
three years right so having these kind
of devices and having a patient being
willing to have that kind of data
tracked kind of helps you to check in on
them without like being as inconvenient
as
maybe a drive to a travel site would be
definitely
yeah i see a bunch of people sharing
different uh
tracking apps and data that we can find
as well yeah maybe we all need to work
on this together
i love this conversation y'all keep
going
this is my favorite topic
i know frank is is pretty big on that
with strava as well i don't think
frank's on today but um
rebecca on the topic of
like learning and
and building teams are there any
resources or books that you found
especially helpful
i would say maybe like less of building
teams and and more about just management
um you know to be completely honest i
struggled when i became a manager for
the first time i was a really good ic
like not to toot my own horn but like i
was a really good ic
and when i first became a data science
manager at nordstrom like it was really
hard
um
delegation specifically like i would
have an ass come in and
you know maybe it was like really quick
turnaround for some like marketing fire
drill and
i would have the thought like it's just
quicker if i do it like i can just do it
and i thought that i was helping my team
by kind of saving them from doing that
but then what i realized is that one i
was actually not giving them opportunity
to shine um and build those
relationships and kind of have that you
know like i i did this thing that was
really impactful and then two i got
super burnt out um so once i was
realizing that i um
started looking at different sorts of
like management books like how can i
kind of build uh that skill set and one
book that i really liked
was called like the hands-off manager um
i can't remember who it's by
but i can like share a link to it and
that really
helped me because i didn't want to be a
manager that was very like micro
managing
but i also you know you have to hold
people accountable and get things done
so i kind of was having that balance
between
you know checking in and making sure
things are moving along with not wanting
to be micro managing so that book in
particular really um sort of helped with
like changing my perspective on how i
can like support my team um and you know
like say like one of my team members is
struggling
or like missing deadlines it's it's
instead of like why are you doing that i
can't believe you're missing deadlines
it's more about like you know i know
that you're capable of this so like
what's going on um and kind of having
that different change in perspective so
that was one resource that really helped
um and then as far as like building data
science teams i took this like coursera
uh
corsair course
that i can't remember what it was called
um but it was talking about building a
data science team and they really
advocated for like your first data
science team should be like a data
engineer
and that was like a really helpful
lesson for me and something that i acted
on and
really ended up being a good fit because
i had a lot of synergy with the data
engineer because you know i had like the
data analysis statistics kind of
background but you know i
never built a database before and kind
of like
that was a nice synergy so i don't have
any
more specific resources than that um
yeah that's really helpful i was
guessing at what they were and putting
them into the chat but
you can tell me later if those are the
right ones
um but i see ethan you had a question on
management do you want to jump in
i won just got back from holidays like
miss a few
in the past couple of weeks um very nice
to see you
rebecca i just want to ask um
because you mentioned about curiosity
and we all strive to learn
ourselves but as the team managers
how do you foster how you
encourage
curiosity within the team
okay so your question is how do i
encourage curiosity within my team
um yeah that's a good question
um in my current role i haven't had to
really encourage it because the person
that i have on my team is
naturally curious and i've worked with
them for a while so it's i would say
it's less about encouraging and more
just we have casual conversations about
um you know what it what are we kind of
interested in um i would say maybe the
thing that i do
with my team that i like um is that we
have like our team meeting on friday
and
we do like different f's so we do like
f'd up friday so like here's something
that i
effed up this week to kind of take away
kind of take away that fear of like
making mistakes you know like let's just
laugh about it and actually share what
you learned from it um
then there's fine work friday so it's
actually you know celebrating like i
really liked the documentation i wrote
because it was super awesome and helpful
um and then the third one is found out
friday so like what's something that you
learned this week and so having that be
kind of part of our
like weekly team meeting i think kind of
you know it becomes part of the dialogue
learning becomes part of the dialogue
like of the team especially at a regular
basis
um in my role at nordstrom i worked with
i had a little bit more junior members
on my team
and
there was
this one team member that i had in
particular who she was super smart and
like very like a very good analyst but
her coding wasn't the strongest um and
so
i kind of just like told her that i
believed in her and that like i i knew
that she could learn it and kind of just
that like belief and encouragement
like kind of helped her
not be afraid to try it i feel like
there's a lot of times like fear of
failure of trying something new so
i'm not sure if i'm answering your
question in a very direct way but i
would say it's more like
building creating space for people to
not know everything and kind of having
the team be about
you know i learned something new or i
learned that something that i thought i
knew was incorrect um so yeah that's a
little bit about how i do that
yeah thank you that's very interesting
to hear about the uh the field of
sharing meetings because um
i've heard about your meetings with
crochet about the achievement that
necessarily
um
openly talk about their effort so very
interesting that you know if you can
encourage people to openly talk about
that then everyone can learn from the
mistakes so usually
someone uh
maybe we push the wrong code to
productions and falsely outage or
whatever it's between you and the
manager to to to solve it and for for
example for a few people but don't say
something you talk openly about the
meeting
yeah and kind of sorry please go ahead i
didn't mean to interact no no
um i was just going to say to kind of
expand on that like i try to take that
culture um also to my to my business
stakeholders as well
um i've had a lot of experiences in the
past where there's some
campaign or something that like my
business stakeholders
did that ended up not being a success
um and then there's a lot of kind of
like weird feelings and your data's
wrong and um
you know kind of like push it under the
rug
and
um so i try to also encourage that like
concept of
uh you know it's like not scaling
something that didn't work is like a
good thing right like even though like
you tried something and this particular
experiment wasn't successful like you
avoided scaling it to our entire
customer base so like you know let's
move on to the next experiment kind of
encouraging more of that
you know failing failing faster
um so that we can kind of iterate
through things and figure out what does
work because most of the time the things
that we're going to do like probably
aren't going to be successful
that's a great point
sloane i see you had a question in the
chat too do you want to jump in
sure um i guess i have two questions so
the first one is did you always know
that you wanted to be a manager and then
also your friday's idea is absolutely
fantastic and i'd be curious to know
more on how you landed on that idea were
you inspired by
um like either you know poor meetings or
was there someone that really inspired
you that you know you got that meeting
idea from or just how how did you come
up with it
so what was your first question yeah
they're kind of unrelated the first one
was just did you always know that you
wanted to be a manager
oh okay got it um
yeah i would say no i didn't always know
that i wanted to be a manager um
i would say it kind of like came out
like naturally um i would find that i'm
always that person in class that like is
asking questions and like makes people
stay longer because they're like asking
so many questions and
people probably get really annoyed at me
for that um but it was kind of like i
really liked the technical work i was
doing but the part that i really liked
is like helping others and sharing my
knowledge um and like building
relationships with with stakeholders and
so kind of though those
things kind of put me in a position
where you know a reorganization was
happening and there was this new manager
role being created and i kind of i like
put my hat in the ring and i said you
know i want to do this and i think i'm
qualified for xyz reasons and kind of
cheryl sandburg my way into that job um
so you know just to try it and i i
believe that career paths are like not
necessarily linear so even though
you know right now like you know i'm the
head of data science like i could see
myself in my career being a
like principal data scientists at some
point so i'm kind of not like making
like a firm commitment to a certain path
but becoming a manager actually gave me
really great perspective on my work as
an ic because you know is that like
imposter syndrome like does my manager
think i'm doing enough like
how how am i working how does my work
compared to other people's and being a
manager really helped me sort of gain
that perspective i was like okay yeah
like i'm pretty good i see
um and then as far as like the found out
uh
i can't remember i mean i think it was
more just like i'm a big fan of like
puns and alliteration
and um tasteful use of the upward so
i would say that's how it kind of came
together and it's just working in a
small environment um and knowing the
people on my team really well i kind of
was like okay i can i can get away with
this
um
but i can't remember like
i can't remember where the idea came
from initially so
so it's not a very good answer to your
question
thank you so much rebecca that's really
helpful
um
oh it says elizabeth over here but i
think it's libby
i guess i could call you both libby i
see you had a follow-up to sloan's
question too
yeah i had a follow-up and kind of like
a
observation from from my experiences is
that
there tends to be like a lack of upward
mobility for data people that doesn't
involve people leadership and i'm
wondering if
maybe to open this up to everybody like
if they work in an organization where
there
there are options for that to become
more of a technical leader or an r d
leader versus a people leader i know
that that kind of environment exists
like at meta you can make the same
amount of money for instance at the same
level as an ic or a people leader um
but
it's been just something i've been
wondering about
david says yes at nasa
uh i i worked with a person at
nordstrom um her name is gina schmalze
and she's just like one of my favorite
humans in the entire world and i think
she's a great example of like a very
like she's she's a leader but she's not
a people manager like just how she
presents herself and like kind of helps
other people learn and so i think that
she she does an amazing job of that
at nordstrom just to kind of share a
specific experience but i think that's a
great really great question
yeah i think for companies who don't
have that it's sometimes hard to make
the case
for that as well
i'm like
carving out that leadership role that
isn't a people manager
david do you want to share any thoughts
on what that looks like at nasa
sure um it will
we we don't have a whole lot of it but
we do have most of the people who are at
the higher level management are going to
be supervisors also but there are a
small group probably about 10 and i'm
just guessing at the at that number
there where myself included i am a
a
manager but i don't do the personnel
things of
what's required of a supervisor i manage
but i don't necessarily supervise the
personnel issues so i don't do time
cards i don't do performance evaluations
i don't do all of those paperwork things
that need to be done for a manager
but i participate in providing feedback
to that i focus on managing the
technical work
managing the focus that and how we do
the technical work and doing that and i
may assign tasks and things like that
but it's all around how we handle the
technical products that we're trying to
to deliver
i see thank you that's really helpful
i know an hour always goes by way too
quickly but just want to check to see
where there are other
questions that i missed and if so if you
want to just like raise your hand or
unmute
i see jordan you unmuted were you going
to ask something
nope
any other questions
i have a quick question um so since
you're the first data scientist
in your team right now and you said you
have to ask a lot of questions from
stakeholders when they ask you questions
how do you help them understand the
difference between interesting questions
just like keep on asking because you're
the only data person they have to go to
versus actually impactful while still
maintaining that relationship with them
yeah i would say that that's a challenge
that
i continue to build my skill set on and
i would say that i'm not always
successful
um i think i sometimes have to weigh the
political capital
that comes with
doing something that's interesting even
though i don't personally think it's the
most impactful so kind of doing a couple
of those things to build the
relationship
um
i don't know maybe that's not the best
way to go about it but kind of once i
got to that point it's more about like
having a conversation about an ask
instead of it being transactional it's
more like okay i understand
that you wanted to look at this um but
actually you know like
what's the why behind this or just being
very
direct and saying you know like what's
the business value or like what action
are you going to take as a result of
this and
you know a lot of times that can help
them be like oh
maybe that's actually like or it's you
know kind of a nice to have and like not
and that kind of comes a lot with like
something that's urgent it's kind of
like understanding like is this really
urgent um so that's you know a challenge
that that i continue to face um
yeah it's a really good question
thank you yeah
thank you so much rebecca this is great
and thank you all for all the great
questions too um
i just wanted to share one more time
before we leave here that we do also
have the linkedin group if people do
want to continue
any discussions there
mostly it's just me posting things and
just like recaps from sessions but would
love to have you all feel comfortable to
post there too so feel free to to use
that
um but rebecca i really appreciate you
sharing your experience and insights
with us this was awesome
yeah thank you so much for having me and
i've got a job so thank you so much for
the great conversation
you